Ready to leave the vault?
Amazon's new Fallout series
is nearly here — and the first trailer
is packed full of fan-friendly details.
Amazon Studios has dropped the first teaser
trailer for its Fallout series. This iconic
post-apocalyptic RPG series continues to be
one of the most popular video game franchises
of all time. Although the series debuted
in 1997, it was 2008's highly immersive
Fallout 3 that turned the series into a
must-play for gamers. For the uninitiated,
players take on the role of an individual
living in a vault made to withstand nuclear
fallout. Through various circumstances,
they're forced out of their comfort zone and
enter an apocalyptic hellscape, confronting
devious humans and terrifying creatures.
The Fallout television adaptation, which comes
from Westworld creatives Lisa Joy and Jonathan
Nolan, will be an original story that's canonical
to the video games. Based purely on the first look
of the series, hardcore fans will be pleased with
the show's direction. The teaser trailer is ripe
with imagery and iconography that's ripped
directly from the video game, such as the
iconic look of the vaults and post-apocalyptic
Earth's many dastardly creatures. There are,
however, some small but important details that
fans might have missed in this first trailer.
"I grabbed a mouldy one."
While the Fallout games take place
in the same universe and timeline,
they're not necessarily interconnected
like traditional sequels. However,
the games feature similar themes, mechanics, and
— sometimes — characters. Perhaps one of the most
interesting "characters" in the franchise is
Dogmeat, a dog who serves as a companion for
the playable character. Dogmeat has become a
prominent part of the Fallout lore, which is
why it shouldn't be surprising that he's set to
make an appearance in the Amazon's adaptation.
And it seems like Dogmeat is making more than
just a cameo appearance in the Fallout series,
as he appears a number of times throughout
the trailer. Featuring Dogmeat in the series
directly ties the show to the video games,
making his appearance a truly fun piece of fan
service. And seeing as there's a different
Dogmeat in each game, the creatives have
carte blanche to create a version of the dog
that perfectly suits the television series.
Meanwhile, in the Fallout lore, there are over
100 vaults — though not all of them have been
explored in the games. With the release of the
television series, fans are on track to see a
brand-new vault that hasn't appeared before.
In the trailer, audiences see the protagonist,
Lucy, leave Vault 33 and set off for the
outside world for reasons as yet unknown.
Little is known about Vault
33, which is what makes it
all the more intriguing. The vault is
located in what was once Los Angeles,
which makes sense considering vaults with low
numbers were built for the West Coast. However,
it looks like something devious is being cooked
up at Vault 33. When we see Lucy step out of
Vault 33 for the first time, a cut can be seen
on her lip. Did she get into a fight? If so,
with whom? Another moment appears to depict total
bedlam happening in a vault — though whether it's
Vault 33 isn't yet known. The Fallout series isn't
shying away from showing that things are imperfect
in both the sheltered and outside world, and it
seems that the series will carry on this theme.
Notably, Fallout will be set in the year 2296
— about 200 years after the apocalypse. The
year in which the show is set is important as
it helps inform fans of when the show takes
place in the larger Fallout timeline.
The franchise's last mainline entry,
Fallout 4, is set in 2287, which means the
television series begins after all the games.
Still, the show features components seen
throughout the franchise. These include the
Power Armors, a key aspect of the franchise in
terms of gameplay and visual recognition. Fans
will also spot the military group Brotherhood
of Steel; their symbol can be seen on the Power
Armors. Another key piece of iconography
ripped from the games is the Vertibird
flying vehicle. First introduced in Fallout 2,
the vehicles are seen briefly in the trailer.
Based purely on the trailer, Fallout seems like
it'll be an authentic adaptation that honors
its source material while offering a unique
story. And while fans no doubt have questions
about the series, all will be answered when
Fallout hits Prime Video on April 12th, 2024.